I need y'all to see this  you're thinking what I'm thinking I mean  maybe of course not you're not  disgusting oh let's make a Funyun  infused Gibson okay yeah  that's it feeling mason jar with Funyuns  then fill it to the top with gin allow  it to infuse for at least eight hours is  it weird I want to eat a moist fondue  now  strange remove the solids and filter it  again with damp the coffee filter Hannah  is a home bartender with years of  experience making unique cocktail  recipes it should look beautifully clear  just like this but this one is weird and  I like weird add three ounces of onion  infused gin to a mixing glass then add  half an ounce of dry removed stir with  plenty of ice strain garnish and enjoy  your Funyun Gibson